I grew up
[Music]
looking out for a place to go
you come to look for a cane
and when you get the chance
[Music]
feel the love
Christmas
foreign
[Music]
you can die
having the time of your life
[Music]
[Applause]
a little contests
[Music]
thank you
surrender
[Music]
Ed
it's always repeating itself
[Music]
finally facing my voice
foreign
[Music]
Christmas
I don't know how to sing about love when
I'm not feeling it
then
sing about what you are feeling
I was cheated by you
and I think you know when
so I made up my mind
you must come to an end
Look At Me Now
now will I ever learn
I don't know how
but I suddenly lose control
There's A Fire Within Myself
[Music]
does it show again my my just how much I
missed out
[Music]
I was angry and sad about the things
that you do
I can't count all the times
[Music]
Here I Go Again
now I really know
[Applause]
not bad you got to work on your
breathing and you were a little pitchy
is what I would say
if I wasn't a loving relative speaking
as a grandmother I'm so proud I can
combust
ER you've got glitter in your veins you
got it from me now I need to find Skye
because he and I were going to talk
about you where is Senor San Diego still
know where Skye is
in fuegos
that's an unusual name he's an unusual
man
see for yourself
Fernando
[Music]
Mexico 1959
can you hear the drums
[Music]
I remember long ago another Starry Night
Like This
[Music]
you are humming to yourself and softly
strumming your guitar I could hear the
Distant Drums and sounds of bugle calls
were coming from afar
and they were close enough
[Music]
every hour every minute seemed to last
eternally
I was so afraid Fernando
we were young and full of life and none
of us prepared to die and I'm not
ashamed to say the Roar of guns and
cannons almost made me cry
[Music]
no we never thought that we could lose
there's no regrets
[Music]
if I had to do the same again
okay
[Music]
now we're old and gray Fernando
since many years I haven't seen a rifle
in love
can you hear the drums
to recall the Fateful night we crossed
the real ground I can sit in your eyes
how proud you ought to fight for freedom
in this land
remember
you and me
[Music]
could lose there's no regrets
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
my God
[Applause]